achava que não ia voltar mais né
tudo aqui gente olha gostaria de falar
para vocês o seguinte ela tem um
jeitinho que ninguém tem o jeitinho que
ninguém tem ela quem cara pálida
eu com seu jeitinho de ano a caixa tem
fibra a mineira o encanto tem a baiana
quanto ibra tem tudo isso e o céu também
a capixaba bonita é de dar água na boca
e além da pernambucana
ai meu deus que coisa louca que
encontrei aqui eu tenho viajado de
dexter europa pela ásia
e justamente aquilo que encontra com
você ou piore
fred cortado da rede de copacabana e
ouro quanto tempó é um bom evento a
mulher amazonense quando é boa é demais
mas a bela cearense não fica para trás
a paulista tem a erva além das graças
que tem ea nordeste na conserva toda
vida eo querer bem mas
eu visse o que a mulher carioca fala que
meu vizinho que ela tem
ae ela tem tanta coisa mais tanta coisa
que nem sabe o que tem nela tenho bem
que tenho bem tenho bem que ela tem que
ninguém bem da verdade gente a mulher
carioca ela tem um jeitinho assim de mim
nem está filmando na verdade a mulher
carioca
ela tem um jeitinho de nenê além do mais
ela é carioca
muito obrigado pela presença de seus
grandes sucessos valeu ia chamar aqui no
palco por favor
todos e todas as pessoas que
participaram passar pelos palestrantes
conselho gente tinha uma coisa
portuguesa mas não fez 15 tinha
condenado jorge e todos os organizadores
por favor com seu jeitinho um dia
vamos até tiroteio nem marcos
confio de shin
obrigado gente caiu
e olhem que o guri theory
como é bom participar via internet cada
lugar que eu vou é uma surpresa
a saída só obrigado pela presença de
todos vocês obrigado aos palestrantes a
todos estão aqui até a próxima próxima
edição do tex